hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play mad
father okay politics in advance I'm a
little sick I've got a cough so I may
start hacking and wheezing and halfway
through the recording but that's why I
haven't had that many new videos I've
had three recording stuff for the past
few days but I'm feeling better today
and I haven't missed a recording day
since I started this channel so I will
not miss now okay I think I got to do is
I just got to go around this guy and
hopefully be able to find it oh I don't
think I can reach
oh you mean cut that rah oh okay so that
didn't work
a wooden plank yeah move the plank and
then smash that zombie in the face with
the oh I didn't wait it well I'm I'm
terribly stupid no oh okay I'm horrible
I'm horrifically stupid okay let's not
do it that way and let's do it the
correct way how about that I gotta move
the plane convenien gotta wait it down
yah yah yah oh yah yah know you can
reach with your little arms move the
blank used I'm an engineer I should have
known that I had a feeling but Oh a
sandbag yes move the sandbag do I need
more weight that is the question I think
the sandbag should do love it all right
any more needed oh I put two on there
that should be good I get ready finish
[Laughter]
okay he is now dead and I am happy
that's the way the world works now
okay so la la la la la la it won't open
clicking click stomp all over your dead
body how do you feel now did i hammer
you right into the ground is that
without dude
great okay
hello birdie thank you for being here
for me to save its luck just like
everything else in this what is that
hydroponics I have no idea what that is
oh it was a dead body in that one what
do we get whoa
it's a puzzle that looks like me all
right let's solve this one easy-peasy
yep OOP oh look I got a little smile
creepy doll like I've eyes though but
that's okay I guess huh huh I apologize
again I'm gonna be doing that a lot huh
I'm okay so don't worry about me I'm not
dying let's see you go here you go there
yeah good
tediousness tediousness mistis you go
there okay and there yeah that picture
is kind of its kind of creepy yeah it's
not so bad
oh well there I bet it's gonna change
once I completed though that seems like
a common theme yeah one more ah yah yah
yay
it looks lovely I heard a sound
somewhere looks like I can open this now
let me save just in case something in
here wants to murder my face off
hello hydroponics is that a gem over
there ah around sleeping medication
folklore magic alchemy uprooted hell is
scream oh wait isn't that isn't that
that thing from Harry Potter the
whatchamacallit the rag ruder whatever
you do hickey it's crash smash Robin
Brum I think those are the those are the
thingies that is talking about the thing
donkeys uh-oh one got out got a jam but
uh I don't know ho I don't want to do
that
take the pot yes tone uprooted Mandrake
then they said the name right there
that's the thing for Mary Potter isn't
it I'm pretty sure it is okay I wonder
what would have happened when my head
have exploded if I had uprooted it right
there I guess I'm gonna use this as a
trap for something over here got a
hammer I'm gonna use it for the dog yeah
but how how do I do that how am i I have
no idea how that oh okay wha
why did I do that
what why did I decide that was a good
idea I knew that was a bad idea of
course I knew that those so stupid you
little girl
why do you gotta be like that okay never
mind whatever there's a hammer here I'm
assuming the hammer is gonna be useful
don't I still got this creepy doll I do
that okay so I need to bash doggy with a
hammer or something I don't know
tunnel dead end somehow I got it I don't
know let's try to uh figure something
else out here won't open okay okay there
must have been something there that I
could have done with that little dolly
that's right I've totally forgotten that
dog has the key so it's got to be
something that I got to do for that dog
so what happens if I run into oh yeah
it's good eight aah Oh miss me miss me
you lead to doggy so what do I do about
that
there's got to be something here where I
can use the pot and then set a trap to
smash it or something without being a
and doing it on myself
uh-huh oh well um what was that sound
wait hang on what is that oh is that the
bird flapping its wings down okay never
mind
mmm there's got to go back and read the
book again because there's got to be
some way that it can help or something
in here
see Mandrake mandragora
[Music]
mmm-hmm
it's gotta be something else here room
room okay all right give me
aha the cracked plant that was it hammer
that sucker smash boom got it got it
what do we have here
junk flows out of the pot anything I
could use in here gosh I hope so
I think this is about it got your oh
that would be magnificently helpful now
can I do the thing with the dog may I
pretty please pretty pretty please with
[Music]
and doggy follow you over
I do not good I am I am too proud to be
killed by lead dog what oh okay it's
just like it look trying to do something
for her smell
it's fainted I thought it would be dead
now I shall kill it
stab you in face sorry I'm not sorry
sorry not sorry
okay do I have the key cool oh yeah I've
totally forgotten I'm here too what what
what the hell happened I don't sound
good what the hell did something happen
oh they got out well that's good that I
have my earplugs I guess alright yeah
let's get out of here and go to the
incinerator does this place isn't Hannah
run Bravo
oh I didn't even notice that door open
yeah well that was terribly stupid of me
haha alright
oh my god oh well that was dumb that was
pretty dumb I only bit that was that was
pretty dumb
okay moving forward let's see what do we
have nobody ah wait no oh yeah that's
right up here use the incinerator key
where I'm gonna burn this what whoa this
is the incinerator it's a pool of lava
it's spouting with flame that's a big
word for a little kid see who knew this
was down here Oh your father you'll have
to destroy that doll if you want to go
further burn it up real good in this
weird with Billy and then BAM because
the invisible barrier around that door
okay let's do it let's do it to it ooh
burn you creepy doll bye-bye
you want to destroy me yeah you're
freaky in Hell huh I pulled open the
door if you do we'll see about that
stop Stewie stop are you how do you know
my name please aya listen to your mother
stop you're not mom mama I want to see
you my sweet you're a liar stop yeah
that's right
die with Frodo in the One Ring or
whatever I don't know Gollum yeah yeah
okay now you burn up real good and you
open that damn door you open that door
for me all right all right all right I
ride these whoa oh yeah that was there
before
okay these are now dead the dolls are
now destroyed good stay that way please
okay now we go back and was that there
before
where did ice it's nothing said that I
had to stop and thank my brain like
caught I didn't never mind my I had an
error in my computron brain the cat
seems to be watching I thought it was
dead yep
I'd not not guess they did all right
let's see what's behind this magical
door I might be getting close to the end
I oh you're still in there little this
place giving me the creeps yawn yep
there we go whoa this is what a portal
this is how doom that started that will
take you to the other world
[Music]
he's up ahead are you truly going a
reality too harsh for such a young lady
maybe awaiting you will you still go
you seem adamant then let me give you
this
what still don't know who you are or
what the hell you want from me what's
this mr. magic water a product of my
company magic water sounds made-up he
take it with you the power kept within
the waters shall no doubt be of help you
can I save my father with this too of
course the water has about to seal the
power of the curse so I can stop the
curse
she must be in pain so I have to save
mom - will mom be able to rest once the
curse is gone yes I'm sure she will if
your love reaches her I'm sure your
mother can be saved okay thank you
mister ah
it was nothing for them madam I pray for
your safety
flappity flap flap flap okay let's go in
let's see what we got here
ja man oh sweet moves do a 360 barrel
roll tuck and oh no I left my chainsaw
so she went in what will she choose I
wonder
Oh Hall I shall see this to the end
oh oh oh it's Santa in his early days
whoa I'm getting some serious earthbound
vibes from this hmm this is the other
world it's like some storybook world
better move on oh it's a new same all
right well I don't know how close I am
to the end but I always know that I like
to contain the end in one point so if I
am close maybe I'm really close like one
step let me just check up on one good
say what okay may or may not be but I
will
alright let's let's just look look
because I might be like right there in
the end who knows found right here at
the end good thing I move forward mom so
you came I ah so it's really you miss mo
you shouldn't have come why why did you
do this you've seen it on your way here
haven't you aya the atrocity this man
continues to commit I don't want any
more victims of his you lie
if anyone understood father it was you
mom
it's Maria you don't like right she
loved father so you didn't like him
getting along I know how you feel
I love father too so I feel like Mario
took father away I was so scared I
couldn't breathe ha ha ha ha ha ha I
know that yes it's all as you say I
couldn't stand to see your father and
Mario together Maria I don't know Mari
so you still love father don't you so
then why are you making him suffer I
don't want to make him suffer I don't
want to give him to anyone so I'm taking
it with me weird
you can't without father I'll be all
alone I don't want that I just wanted to
live with father and you mom take me
with you too please I can't possibly do
that I want you to live and be happy
I can't I'm happy when I'm with father
and mom so don't leave me alone
yeah oh that's not good that's not a
good time no one shall interfere
all right then
mom now honey let us go no fat her ha ha
yeah
yeah hey look you can finally see his
eye he doesn't look so good father what
did i do I have no idea what I did
father oh yeah
why won't you listen to your mother
don't take father away out of my way no
one shall have him mom stop
he is mine alone
you're kind of crazy ain't you what's
this mr. magic water a product of my
company the power of kept within shall
no doubt be of help to you
you you I can save father with this or
what about mom if your love reaches her
I'm sure your mother can be saved
really I'm really not sure what should I
do
save father ha ha she's crazy
no joke I'll save father what that whoa
what happened I don't know what happened
uh uh uh yeah what are you doing I'm
sorry mom
magic water goes top ayah ah whoa cool
graphics for an RPG
oh it switched again she's glowing I'm
fat I'm fading I thought that said I'm
far dying
my body is disappearing mom yeah no
don't go
Oh
as families kind of crazy
and she's gone it's probably for the
best
she seemed to be a little bit crazy
cuckoo I don't know what the other
ending could have been but I have no
idea oh hello well this is different
where am I
father are you all right you don't look
so good Oh was I oh yeah
huggles father uh yeah I'm sorry aiya
I worried you so father mom yes I know
she must have been lonely we'll visit
her grave tomorrow so her spirit won't
be okay
oh oh I I didn't want you to know the
truth with the last of my power oh oh
did I make the wrong choice what I
probably made a fine simple I shall
dispose of the remaining materials
myself that can wait
come Maria doctor shut up nurse make out
with me that's how I make out so yeah
just to ruin all the fangirl fancies or
I build them up I don't know she's aware
of our relationship what does it matter
I don't believe she's fond of me that is
the problem the girl will be 11 soon
troublesome able to be sure be kind to
her make sure she is never harmed she's
my most precious doll of them all dun
dun dun what huh a doll me oh I see was
that huh this is now what
uh-oh Oh mom
swoosh you're a ghostie girl he's been
always spending all this time down the
basement don't tell me he's with that
girl again
dr. mistress aya has become rather
ladylike and to think she always used to
tease you and bother you ha ha ha ha
just a little more I think a little more
until she's ripe I want to make her into
the most beautiful doll I can what what
was that she shall be the masterpiece of
all the dolls I've made the halls wha
what make her into a doll mom what is
this I shall clean up the unnecessary
materials please do I'll never forgive
you
you'll never make our precious daughter
into one of your subjects huh
you what's the meaning of this
are you planning to experiment on her so
you overheard what are you thinking
she's our one and only treasure exactly
such a wondrous daughter I want to make
her eternally so and yet she will
someday be dirtied that I cannot bear to
think so I will make her a doll I don't
believe this
I'll never let you do that I'm leaving
what are you saying you wanted Oliver so
badly just make a replica wait are you
planning to take her away that I cannot
allow let go I won't let you do that you
will I won't let you do what you will
with her Oh mom uh-oh aah
No Oh milady doctor what have you done
Milady's stay with us Oh doctor why did
you do this it had to be done but I is
future lady don't speak of this tyre
[Music]
she was already feeble she passed away
from her I can't tell her that you
refusing my order but no that's not what
I meant
Maria shut up nurse whatever happens I
am loyal to you doctor
because you are my assistant huh doctor
now how shall we dispose of the body
naturally ah I must not see it cast it
into the incinerator
really
[Music]
this story is messed up is this a dream
am I just having a dream it's no dream
this is reality
Bob I'm sorry I yeah
your mother still loved your father even
now so I didn't kill him but I should
have don't say that run away away from
him
oh yeah what's wrong
what'd he look so afraid of your father
I'm starting to get the idea of this oh
oh boy huh very good
not mater oh yeah what I just saw was it
the truth father you very well
Fath well I don't you think your
mother's beautiful yeah I suppose it's a
bit much to take it
I just wanted just a little more time
but father couldn't make me a doll don't
be sad yeah
by making you a doll your beauty can
last forever
look at these children beautiful yes
preserved just as they were when alive
this is the fruit of my research moving
am I gonna be like that you can hardly
even tell they're dolls can you but the
heads eyes tall Zoe's hands legs they
were gathered from a wide array of
people I find it quite fascinating
combine a dog with a human if you so
desire
isn't that incredible what would you
like to be aiya alas I can't make many
changes while preserving your loveliness
father stop ah yes
perhaps I'll dress you up so finely tell
me whatever you wish to wear no uh-uh
don't run away from me come be by your
father no no are you refusing your
father I'm sorry I don't wanna be a doll
and now I run really fast Lee I made the
rad the bad choice wait what is you a
mannequin doll okey-dokey
oh it won't open
whoa okay uh yeah Thank You mr.
mannequin thank you
uh yeah it's really weird suddenly a
voice came out of nowhere
open up I don't have my chainsaw oh no
oh boy that's not good that's pretty bad
sorry mr. mannequin okay
holy crap please no maybe I don't know
what to do I don't know what to do ya
mad father making a lot more sense now
oh oh no oh oh no oh I got it I got I
got a bull rush him so that he like I
gotta make him slam into the door with
this no no no what I wanted hate you God
oh no I'm back here got really really a
gosh darn doofus there we go okay we're
good yeah if I had my chainsaw you'd be
you'd be going down papi okay so I think
I gotta like make them rush the door
I think cuz I can dodge him I'll cut on
I can't turn right there
oh sorry this is taking so long
apparently I'm stupid cuz
apparently yeah I can come on come on
come on what do I do
what am I to do ah I don't know what I'm
supposed to do won't open what do I do
about that
solutions gotta be obvious it's gotta be
it's gotta be oh there's a switch over
there I just saw that from Brum
kachunk what did that do nope rum rum
okay that opened the thing there we go
alright we're good oh hello where is
this was that returned dr. mistress
Mario don't let I escape oh wait well
good job trying to stop me what do we do
left right left right let's go left oh I
don't remember any of these places won't
open Oh what do I do
I don't know hide see there's a save
point here man this is taking longer
than I thought I would have stopped it
before if I'd had known that the ending
would wasn't like right there god this
part is going on forever
[Music]
okay I close the door what good did that
do me no corpse here I can hide here
okay there we go
mistress where where did I ago I
apologize I lost sight of her what I'm
terribly sorry
I'm certain she could not be far let's
search elsewhere you you saw really
really really man is such an a-hole such
an a-hole such a nail I don't like that
guy oh man poor her that's gotta suck Oh
doctor Marya what do I do
so much blood is there anything here I
could use shady drugs is there anything
here maybe got a bandage on that'll do I
guess see use the bandage a bandage will
I can't wrap this around your clothes
lift your skirt a little Mario no stop
it stop it stop it no
it should help stop the blood mistress
thank you for caring for me it's fine
don't worry about it I should be most
loathsome in your eyes don't say that
it's true I know how you feel mistress I
took away your most beloved of course
you would hate me but you are very kind
to show me such compassion Marya ah a
man Mario can you stand mistress let's
get out of here together but mistress
I'm the same as you Mario
I can't live without father's love but
if father doesn't want us we've been
abandoned we have to live without it now
even though you and I can't live alone
so we'll help each other to keep living
even if father's gone mistress
[Music]
I shall accompany you off Marya palsies
mistress but could I have your shoulder
okay
so gonna save real quick man I did not
expect this uh part to go on for so long
and all this talking is like wrecking my
throat I'm not is not that great while
they're still looking okay so we'll go
this way
I really should have stopped right then
and there but I I really had no idea
that it was gonna take this long
ah but hopefully I can finish it out
shout out your crazy bastard
mistress hurry oh oh Marya never mind me
escape no I can't go any further you
must escape alone it can't be it is fine
I shall not leave you alone I will
follow behind for sure believe me please
are you sure about that oh oh I didn't
even get a choice oh come on dick giant
douche I got a run now though oh man
I'll be ending soon my throat is not
doing well all these voices oh okay
let's go let's go come on
Oh dad not good I'm not good oh I got
through wait a minute I remember this
place fighting on the other door would
have led to there what oh hi who the
hell are you he can be with us
No
that's enough of our game of tag alia I
have to keep you still don't I let go I
should be bit quieter now my throat is
actually really hurting I didn't want to
hurt you I it's shame
now stop father but I can cover your leg
with a skirt easily enough so it should
be fine I don't want this I wanted to
stay with father I Love You Father
so please stop this I don't worthy worry
father and I are we'll always be
together now so rest in peace I am I
love there you go go yeah father I love
you in my own crazy crazy way there you
go
fart her
was that Maria's doing there we go
thought so
[Music]
thank you all right you're good with
those knives mistress Maria are you hurt
sniff Maria Oh father isn't moving good
father die
I apologize mistress I have no choice
left to protect you no other choice left
but to protect you
okay I guess it's for the best right mom
oh how is that even possible you know
you gotta forget you got a friggin knife
in your head man that should not have
been possible oh okay good deus ex
machina right there basic ex machina I'm
glad I made it I thought you were dead
and I thought the curse was lifted
mistress
[Music]
okay all right is that is it anything
else happening is this the 10 minute
long conclusion oh man
I really should have broken this up but
I did not you saved us
thank you no need for thanks I just did
what she asked you mean my mom I said I
was sorry for scaring you I didn't
intend to get injured believe that at
least I understand mom wanted to protect
me thank you mom
oh is that the bunny by my side I want
to see you again she wanted that too but
I don't think she wanted to be seen as
she is now that's whatever mom looks
like I it's all right
she's watching you from afar so don't be
sad if you are it'll only make her sad
right the curse will wear off soon so
it's almost farewell you'll go away
we're all alive now only because of the
curse I see but there's something I must
do before I go and that is set fire to
this mansion good idea why would you
can't do that all those memories are
being happy here
that's not my intent to burn those but
it's possible that someone could find
traces of your father here we can't let
the same tragedy happen again is that
what mom wanted to
mmm-hmm okay if that's what mom wanted
then do it mistress it's okay Mario even
if this house is gone my memories of
father and mom won't go mistress yes
that's right
aya there's one more thing I ask of you
do not ever forget the people who were
sacrificed here none of us had any
relatives no one looked for us no one
remembered us no one knew we existed at
all our existence will be forgotten to
the world but we did indeed live so I
don't want you to forget that I want you
to hold proof in your heart that we were
here that is the least you can do for us
yes I will never forget thank you
well this is goodbye oh that was quick
you want to do that after I get out
maybe guess on the forehead just like
the book in the beginning said goodbye
hyah
may you be smiled upon Oh
now go
and I'm trying goodbye I'm trying to go
cuz the whole house is on fire
come here fluffer nutters let's go
squeeze
[Music]
Oh
and there's father the curse is still
like there would he rise from the dead
oh hello mr. humans are such utterly
foolish creatures I have seen countless
many foolish humans but you are the most
foolish of them all a human mad with
desire is more fearsome than any demon
and yet I adore such foolish humans come
to me come to me and you may research to
your heart's content
okay that's not good that's not good at
all it is just the two of us now well
and snowball pehoe yes that's right what
shall we do now I don't know we have to
find somewhere to live but I'm sure I
can't live alone
Marya will you come with me yes of
course you have taught me much mistress
now it is time for me to help you
whatever awaits us I wish to protect you
all the way thank you
[Music]
let's go are you sure with watch
watching to the end yeah it's fine
actually I wonder where that guy with
the black coat went I kinda hope he's
okay oh I'm sure he's just fine come
here fluffer nutters I'm sure he'll be
all right bone he's a really strange guy
come on Britt Auburn otters
father mother goodbye what's this
a book
oh boy more stuff to read my throat is
really hurting guys mistress
um what is the matter nothing let's go
the mistress is very Hardy even after
that harsh experience she walks on
without shedding a tear with the
mistress beside me I can feel I feel we
can overcome anything however what is
this uneasiness I feel doctor
[Music]
I'm finally here I've heard about this
place drevis clinic clinic the ass this
must be the place it's out in the middle
of nowhere no one would even notice it
no dark um hello ah a patient welcome
she's so pretty
is she the doctor what seems to be the
problem yes well I was born rather
feeble I've asked my local doctor for a
checkup but how do you
I say this my family is really poor so
my doctors given up on me that's why I
came here I heard the doctors here does
free checkups for free yes we don't ask
any money from our patients so don't
worry really I honestly don't have any
so I can really get examined of course
thank you so much
what's your name I'm Jean Jean Jean Jean
Rooney Jean that's a wonderful name I'm
a addres vez nice to meet you Jean yes
you too ah yeah I can do that I've been
meaning to do that that doesn't sound
good we should examine you right away oh
really you think come in come in
considering you're not all that healthy
your legs sure carried you a long way
was it difficult for you I met a kind
old woman on the way here who took me
part of the way on coach it was so nice
of her there were some really nice
people out there just like you doctored
Reavis hehe you think so
is this where things turn sinister she
takes after her father now lie down here
when I strap you to the tables and get
my knives boy I'm nervous
yoosh oh that's a horse what the hell
are they in the back and see it see stay
very still while I apply the anesthesia
ah yes why does she need anesthesia
you're very pretty eyes you know oh so
beautiful I can't stop looking at them
uh-oh no one's ever said that to me
before thank you very much he nervous
it's fine just relax your shoulders
doctor um doctor do you think you can
make me better
of course from now on you'll never
suffer again so take it easy and go to
sleep
[Music]
indeed the mistress is much like you it
does run in the family
Oh doctor I got a bad feeling about that
ending I'm really sorry about my throat
man that went way longer than I thought
this part was gonna be I had no
intention of even recording more than
four this went on for fifty minutes
about I had no intention of recording
that long today but I tried my best to
keep up with it I apologized my voice
was not 100% in all the scenarios but I
hopefully you guys still enjoyed it
nonetheless that was a really cool
ending um it was really really cool I
feel good right now but hopefully you
guys still enjoyed the game that was
like really cool um III actually I knew
the father was crazy but I didn't know
that he was that crazy towards the end
so that was really unexpected and and
pretty cool um I believe this is made by
the same guy that made the witch's house
and you know II but which I may play
next um so if you got suggestions that
you want me to play next hopefully you
can put them in the comments below I'm
gonna go rest up gargle some salt water
eat some ice cream or something cuz man
my voice feels like it feels like
bleeding in my throat it's not a good
set so excuse me so anyway um if you
want I know I didn't get all the gems I
got close but I didn't get them all I
think it was like four short if you want
to see all the gems ending a manga minx
has a great playthrough this where she
does it way better than I do and I think
she has an ending where do all the gems
are gotten so if you want to see what
the special endings are all about you
can go to her channel I'll try to link
the video where the ending is in the
description you can check that out
I'm also if you don't want that you can
find out you can find out different
things from very just search on youtube
you'll find it anyway so if there was a
secret that I missed hopefully you can
find it later so I think this is
officially the end yep it is the end
okay the title screen has changed too so
anyway
you all so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]